I also go breasts my name no no are you
crying
you know we're gonna have fun together
you and I they say the goat can't ride a
car
I say off-road [ __ ] damn it yeah
Oh God they say you should ride the car
I say take the car for a ride
Helen [ __ ] sake what happened how did
you know it was my birthday
hey now it's a party oh yeah yeah she's
breaking bad oh my gosh yes it's just in
there
Jessie Jessie Jessie
some say bicycles existed before the
take this [ __ ] prize for the day we
put this giant bar in the water how am I
supposed to bicycle a giant
it's so hard to [ __ ] do anything why
am i flying why am i flying yeah yeah
let's jump from this Terrace did not a
day that is impressive how do you have
such a well maintained stream especially
through those pants no don't stop
because oh you're coming with me you're
my new best friend
can we ride a bicycle for Perry yes we
can
Obama said it yes riding a bike
damn it Harry you had one job
oh lava Allah Allah
okay this is not what I wanted when I
walked up the stairs okay that's better
Jesus Christ what happened what happened
look at this look at this [ __ ] look at
it [ __ ]
my friends you did it okay what about
this thing yeah strongest goat that has
launched an elephant to space oh yes yes
of course I saved your life after a
freak accident at the carnival Bessie
the elephant was transported back in
time she became
don't worry about it friends
I will save you
I will save you all I'll explain I'm
sorry oh my god
yeah fabulous good fabulous p.m. police
oh I just had an abortion this was I
will cure world hunger with this
everyone will be so happy
it's so [ __ ] disturbing
Oh Oh
framerate it's happening well I better
jump in looks like and that episode
there if you enjoyed punch that live
buck with your nipple try it out
leave a comment about goatse and I will
see you bros in the next one as always
stay awesome bros hey where you going
that's right